look at the history of
chris pincher
there were allegations about chris
pincher
way back in the may government which he
denied when they were investigated they
were found not to be correct he was then
promoted into government he became a
minister
so
there were of course
allegations in the past on the specific
allegations
the prime minister did not know and i
think
he as soon as he found out uh he acted
and acted decisively that's the right
thing to do there is now due process
that has to follow and it's right that
that happens the investigation takes
place and of course uh chris spencer has
to um you know answer those questions
from the investigators well you and i
both know the rumors were rife about uh
mr pincher of all the jobs to throw his
way
it's like putting the goat to mind the
cabbages why
deputy chief whip
well
first of all you will also know that the
values of this country are about you
know innocence um
until proven guilty um those allegations
that were historic that chris denied um
turned out not to be correct when they
were investigated which allowed theresa
may to make him a minister in the first
place um
and of course
then to be made a deputy chief whip
on the
specific incident that took place
uh he wrote to the prime minister saying
that clearly he's let himself and uh the
country down uh and has referred himself
for specialist help and of course
there's an investigation
you know i think due process is
important in these things
and that should be allowed to be
followed